Traductor: María González Durán
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Buenas noches.
Bienvenidos, hijos del rock and roll.
Dibujé una puerta violeta en la pared
En un lugar de la Mancha...
de cuyo nombre no quiero acordarme.
Quizá porque mi niñez
sigue jugando en tu playa.
Contamíname.
Mézclate conmigo.
Que cada uno da lo que recibe
y luego recibe lo que da.
Estas son algunas canciones.
Hay otras que seguro que
hemos cantado, bailado, gritado...
Hasta el amanecer.
O frases de algunos libros
que hemos leído
y luego hemos subrayado.
Y luego más adelante hemos compartido
en Facebook e Instagram.
No sé quién no ha leído una frase
u oído una canción, o visto
una secuencia de televisión.
O se ha quedado delante de una obra
durante un rato en un museo
y no le ha removido algo.
¿A quién no le ha inspirado?
¿A quién no le ha dado la valentía
para "echar pa'lante"?
Para dar un paso hacia adelante. No sé.
¿O le ha hecho imaginar
que otros mundos son posibles?
Uno más uno son siete.
Quién me lo iba a decir.
(Aplausos)
¿A quién no le evoca esta frase
a algún recuerdo de su vida?
Desde luego ha cambiado
mi vida completamente.
A quién... no sé.
Vamos a partir del paradigma de que
me identificáis automáticamente...
con esa canción.
¿Vale? Ya está.
Ya estamos presentados.
Nos relajamos.
¿Por qué? Porque, bueno, me dio
a conocer ante el gran público.
Pero yo creo que también es por otra cosa.
Creo que es porque la cultura nos conecta.
Nos vincula emocionalmente con cosas.
Lo creo firmemente.
Tal vez esta frase de esta canción...
Pues no sé.
Por ahí, os recuerde a vuestra infancia.
A los de allí, a la adolescencia,
cuando erais jóvenes.
No sé. A lo mejor os trae
un recuerdo agradable.
O a lo mejor os provoca rechazo.
También puede pasar.
Sobre todo, por el final de la serie.
(Risas)
¡No lo escribí yo! ¿Vale?
Yo canté la canción. Eso sí.
Sí la canté, la canté.
Pero antes de cantar la canción
pasaron muchas cosas, eh.
Pasaron unas cuantas cosas
que me llevaron hasta allí.
Yo fui un niño aquí en Málaga,
con unos padres aficionados al teatro...
a la danza, a la música,
a la cultura en general.
El primer concierto al que
me llevaron mis padres
a mí y a mi hermana
con cuatro o cinco años
fue al de "Bienvenidos" de Miguel Ríos.
Aquí en la Malagueta.
Yo flipé. Flipé. Ese niño
que iba al teatro con sus padres
de pequeñito se quedaba fascinado con
la magia que se producía en el escenario.
Y con cómo el público reía, lloraba,
estaba en vilo...
Así que ese gusanillo de la infancia
fue despertando un impulso mayor
y al final terminé dedicándome
profesionalmente a ello.
Y si miro atrás, me sorprende muchísimo
y me doy cuenta de que la cultura
me ha hecho mejor persona,
me ha convertido en alguien mejor.
Y hoy estoy aquí para contaros un secreto.
Vuestras vidas también pueden mejorar
a través de la cultura. Sí, sí.
Os puede convertir en mejores personas.
Estoy seguro de ello. Y tengo argumentos.
Y os lo voy a comentar. Si os parece bien.
Yo creo que la cultura es riqueza
para el alma y para las emociones.
¿Por qué? Porque pone palabras a esas
emociones. Hay veces que nos pasa algo
dentro que no sabemos qué es.
Te preguntas qué te está pasando.
Y de pronto escuchas una canción,
lees un libro, ves una obra de teatro
una película, y dices:
"Ah, me pasaba esto".
El ejemplo típico, cuando te enamoras
o te separas, que todas las canciones
hablan de ti... ¡No!
No está escrita para ti.
Es que hay alguien en algún momento
de la historia de la vida
que se ha dedicado a escribir para
que tú luego lo asimiles como tuyo
y no te sientas tan solo o tan sola y te
ahorres una pasta en psicólogos, además.
La cultura nos hace vivir experiencias
que no podríamos vivir de otra manera.
Y no hablo solo por mí en la parte
de actor que me toca.
Sería imposible estar todo el día
interpretando a un Don Juan, ¿no?
Hablo de vivir una odisea en el espacio.
De hablarle a una pelota de vóley
en una isla después de naufragar;
hablo de agobiarte porque no puedes
ayudar a salir a esa criada
en El cuento de la criada.
La cultura nos ayuda a dar pasos
importantes en nuestra vida.
Estoy convencido de ello.
En 2010 saqué un disco que se llama
Viejos conocidos, lo produje yo.
Fue después del boom de Los Serrano.
Fue un disco que produje yo
y fue un esfuerzo titánico.
Además no fue bien,
sé que no lo habéis comprado...
No os preocupéis.
Aquello me dejó exhausto
y dejé de componer un tiempo.
Dije... Mira no puedo más.
Estoy... como para abajo.
Pues hace unos años Pedro Guerra
me invitó a un concierto que daba
en Libertad 8, el mítico garito madrileño
de calle Libertad.
Que fue un concierto precioso,
con la guitarra solamente.
Bueno, pues el Fran que entró a
ese concierto no fue el Fran que salió.
Yo era otra persona.
Me había cambiado completamente.
Y ese día decidí que iba a volver
a componer.
Empecé a tocar la guitarra otra vez.
A componer... Y bueno, hace unos meses
saqué un disco; esto es promoción también.
¿Os dais cuenta de la importancia?
La cultura puede darnos la felicidad.
Hace unos días leí un estudio de la
Universidad Goldsmiths, de Londres.
Que dice que ir a un concierto aumenta
la esperanza de vida. ¿Cómo te quedas?
(Aplausos)
Si señor. Aumenta la esperanza de vida.
Dice el estudio que 20 minutos
en un concierto aumenta un 21 %
la sensación de bienestar.
Un 21 %. Me suena la cifra.
¿Igual nos cobraban el IVA por eso no?
Maldita sea.
Este estudio dice que además si eres
reincidente. Vas a conciertos a lo loco...
tu esperanza de vida puede aumentar
hasta nueve años.
¿Quién no quiere vivir nueve años más?
Hay un poco de escepticismo por ahí,
¿quizá?
Tengo mi segundo argumento, ¿vale?
El primero era el alma.
Pero bueno si... el alma no,
tenemos el de la educación.
Cultura es riqueza por la importancia
y por su aportación a la educación.
Porque nos pone en la piel de otras
personas. Básicamente.
La cultura nos ayuda a salir de nuestra
realidad y dejar de mirarnos el ombligo
e irnos al de otras personas
que tienen otros problemas.
Y eso nos ayuda a ser más solidarios,
más tolerantes, a tener menos prejuicios.
Y a empatizar. Algo que
de verdad me encanta.
De lo que he aprendido,
es de lo que más disfruto.
Dicen los expertos que hay
dos maneras de aprender.
Una es estudiando. De toda la vida.
Vaya que hay que ponerse.
Y la otra es escuchando a gente que sabe
sobre algún tema. Escuchas y aprendes.
Consumiendo cultura aprendes
sobre otras realidades.
Hay un ejemplo muy reciente.
Que ha ocurrido hace muy pocos días
en la gala de los Goya.
La película Campeones de Javier Fesser.
Lo que ha ocurrido con esa película es
maravilloso. El discurso de Jesús Vidal
ni te cuento. Pero esta película
de pronto nos ha puesto la realidad
de la discapacidad delante... o de las
capacidades diferentes como ellos decían.
Con muy buen criterio.
Y yo creo que alguien que no tenga ningún
contacto con gente en esas condiciones...
yo creo que esa película les abre
los ojos de una manera maravillosa.
Efectivamente, ponerse en la piel
del otro nos hace ser menos egoístas
e intentar trabajar para mejorar la vida
de otras personas en nuestro día a día.
Y eso al final nos producirá
una sensación maravillosa.
¿Hay escepticismo todavía por ahí?
Tengo un tercer argumento.
El de aquí. El material.
La cultura es riqueza por el dinero
para un país.
La economía cultural cada vez tiene
más protagonismo, y no lo digo yo.
Lo dice la Unesco y la denomina
"economía naranja".
Dice que ninguna sociedad puede
prosperar sin cultura y sin ella
cualquier desarrollo no es sostenible.
Yo no soy experto en cifras eh.
Pero os voy a dar algunas.
En el año 2017 los conciertos
de música en vivo
recaudaron EUR 300 millones.
Las artes escénicas recaudaron
más de EUR 200 millones.
Se vendieron más de 100 millones
de tiques de cine
y 13 millones de turistas extranjeros
de los 82 millones
que vienen a visitarnos,
lo hicieron por motivos culturales.
No soy experto en cifras, pero estas
suenan bastante bien.
Esto apunta bien.
En 2013 nos juntamos un grupo de actores
y montamos una obra de teatro que se llama
Feel Good, y nos dimos cuenta de que
la cultura nunca estaba sobre la mesa
en el debate político.
Entonces, decidimos
hacer nuestra aportación
a la economía naranja con un vídeo
que os pongo ya.
¿Genera riqueza el teatro?
Eso nos preguntamos nosotros.
Así que en 2013 fundamos
una compañía de teatro
y nos propusimos autoproducir
la obra Feel, de Alister Beaton.
Empezamos por crear empleo
para seis actores,
un director, un ayudante de dirección
y una traductora.
Luego llegó el montaje, que ocupó
a dos actores más, una directora
y un equipo de rodaje, una empresa
de producción, director de iluminación,
escenógrafa, músico, diseñadora
de vestuario y una empresa
de distribución de teatro, imprenta,
tiendas de ropa y de muebles,
publicista, fotógrafo, diseñador de web.
Empezamos la gira y la familia creció.
Dos técnicos, transporte
para la escenografía,
dos agencias de comunicación,
un cámara y editor de vídeo, otro fotógrafo.
Una sola obra de teatro ha creado
más de 30 empleos directos.
Y eso sin contar los empleos indirectos.
Trenes y aerolíneas, empresas de alquiler
de coches, peajes, gasolina, cafeterías,
hoteles, medios de comunicación,
plataformas de venta de entradas,
el mantenimiento de los puestos de trabajo
de los teatros que visitamos.
Bares y restaurantes, cargadores
de móviles olvidados...
En los dos años de vida de Feel Good,
tuvimos más de cien funciones
y 60 000 espectadores pagaron
su entrada con su 21 % de IVA incluido
para venir al teatro; es como
si toda Ávila, o Cuenca o Segovia,
o Huesca hubiera venido a vernos;
en los peores años de crisis de España
Feel Good ha generado y movido entre
salarios, impuestos, seguridad social,
beneficios... más de EUR 400 000.
A ver si al final va a resultar
que la cultura no es un gasto,
sino una inversión.
Aunque después de tantos números,
sin duda la mejor cuenta de resultados,
el mayor beneficio, es el superávit que
el teatro aporta a nuestras almas.
La cultura es algo excepcional,
no es solo ocio y entretenimiento.
La cultura y la creación son un referente
primordial en la formación del ser humano.
Pues eso.
(Aplausos)
Lo mejor que tiene la cultura
es compartirla.
Reprimamos esta fiera condición,
esta furia, esta ambición
por si alguna vez soñamos.
¡Y sí, haremos! Estamos en un mundo
tan singular que vivir solo es soñar
y la experiencia me enseña que el hombre
que vive sueña lo que es hasta despertar.
Nace el rey y vive con este engaño
mandando, gobernando y este aplauso
que recibe prestado, en el viento escribe
y en cenizas le convierte la muerte.
¡Desdicha fuerte! ¿Qué hay de quien
intenta reinar viendo que ha de despertar
en el sueño de la muerte?
Sueña el rico en su riqueza
que más cuidados le ofrece;
sueña el pobre que padece
su miseria y su pobreza;
sueña el que a medrar empieza,
sueña el que agravia y ofende,
sueña el que afana y pretende,
y en el mundo, en conclusión,
todos sueñan lo que son,
aunque ninguno lo entiende.
Yo sueño que estoy aquí
destas prisiones cargado,
y soñé que en otro estado
más lisonjero me vi.
¿Qué es la vida? Un frenesí.
¿Qué es la vida? Una ilusión,
una sombra, una ficción,
y el mayor bien es pequeño:
que toda la vida es sueño,
y los sueños, sueños son.
(Aplausos)